[Musique]
les derniers espoirs se sont éteints ni
pro enterrémor et a perdu toute chance
de retrouver d'autres survivants les
recherches sont désormais terminées de
sans appartement ont été détruits et 45
personnes ont perdu la vie au bois-tu
voir l'appartement qui n'est plus là où
étaient mes enfants mon petit-fils qui
ont péri en un seul instant
soyez maudit [__] de Poutine et tout
son entourage d'ordures
Moscou qui parle d'une tragédie assure
que ce drame pourrait être dû à un tir
de la défense anti-aérienne ukrainienne
une hypothèse balayée d'un revers de
main par Kiev et les chancellerie
occidentales ces dernières accusent
directement l'armée russe lors d'une
visite à Washington le Premier ministre
néerlandais a rappelé que Vladimir
Poutine doit être directement tenu pour
responsable des atrocités en Ukraine sur
la question de la responsabilité nous ne
pourrons jamais accepter que poutiner la
Russie sentir impunément il faut donc
leur demander des comptes les traduire
en justice s'assurer que tout cela se
fasse de manière légale c'est crucial et
je sais que vous et moi travaillons sur
ce point
l'Ukraine qui fait face à une forte
offensive russe dans la région de barmut
prend le drame de ni pro en exemple pour
dénoncer la barbarie de l'armée de
Moscou et demandait des armements plus
importants à ses alliés ces derniers
jours et pour la première fois Londres a
notamment annoncé la livraison de
charlour à Kef les Européens
s'inquiètent d'une poussée russe et
d'une éventuelle nouvelle mobilisation
de plusieurs centaines de milliers
d'hommes par Vladimir Poutine dans les
semaines à venir